everyone hey welcome back to yet another
episode of watching The Watchmen this is
our second episode very very new podcast
very excited to be doing this though
first episode was a lot of fun to do we
are going through the entirety of Alan
Moore and Dave Gibbons Watchmen which is
you know number one New York Times
bestseller one of Time Magazine's best
novels all-time just a genuinely
brilliant you know a masterpiece really
I think in myself and death sighs and as
I say I'm joined Tom Tom Queen myself
I'm joined by definition how to go man
what's happening everyone how's it going
thanks for checking this out remember we
are a podcast now as well so get
yourself on the bloody iTunes podcast or
and press subscribe press it three times
so don't press it twice because then you
wouldn't subscribe yet three times to
make sure that it is definitely
listening yeah so yeah we didn't make it
clear on the first of it because we
weren't actually progress but now we are
so yes sir system says watching The
Watchmen we should be available on
pretty much any service iTunes downcast
pocket casts if we're not available let
us know we'll submit the theme you'll
get available there so yeah roll over
there let us know Tom well well that's
thanks to the fans are asking about
there is the the best way is watching
The Watchmen pod at gmail.com which I
appreciate it's quite a long sort of
moniker their sort of address but on our
thumbnail it's there I love description
but yeah watching The Watchmen pod or
one more did you wanna come get in touch
of us there
let us know via contact so let us also
what we really want is you know how did
you get into Watchmen where are you
listening from you know great to hear
from people always answer back you know
on the show and by email as well let us
know what you know about you like about
watching them what issue wrong opinions
you have things you disagree what I said
agree echo whatever so watching The
Watchmen part at gmail comment the best
way to get in touch was there Ross on
iTunes but I'm yeah I mean are you
joining us on the second chapter as it
were the second issue have some friends
which is a fantastic issue I guess
generally before we get into this death
like the contents of this particular
portion of story loads great sort of
inside the past yes it's really dark as
well it's kind of where you realize how
much of a bad guy the comedian was
mm yeah so this is like the page funeral
and basically takes place across this
entire issue and everyone to remember
and all the good that eat it right it is
ridiculous isn't it because if you sort
of anticipate the first issue and just
reading it off that valid context you
kind of the comedian I can't remember
exactly what's revealed of I'm obviously
there's something shady but it's nothing
too explicit like it's more mention than
actually shown but yet in this we get
you know to seems specifically the sort
of the [ __ ] most heinous thing the
human can do really but yeah you know he
he or Annika Lee does both of them and
as ever we always have to start with the
that the cover we can always make
transitions into the first panel I love
the cover I'm or the only one that's
seeing maybe too little of you to sort
of be the blood splatter is the tear of
rain yeah this is a little tear coming
out that statue normally she's a bit of
a statue right but just shedding it tear
this time yelling try that joke down
that's I'm not copy writing that no no
that is a standard video on watching
where mod do you want to come let us
know but I mean yeah it's what I like
about the statue is it's realistic in
the sense they're you know it's quite
beautiful from afar just seen the first
kind of but up close it's very dirty and
grimy yeah it's really it's like that
the hair especially it's just covered in
motocross yeah yeah we can sort of see
the background of the city with the
Zeppelin's as well yeah there's a Empire
State Building just in the far right
corner I didn't even see it just reading
the page but you if you rip that page
out tear it out your book right now and
you'll actually see in the corners the
Empire State Building so it sort of
gives the place is also another Zeppelin
up at the top so you can kind of see
yeah you know it's a bit it's a bit of a
New York but it's got a little different
different things going on that you would
normally see yeah yeah and I mean
there's the Geo Dome as well sort of
underneath my chin isn't away yes which
I guess kind of you might see Monza's
and also there's like the antenna dish I
think on that roof as well the lower
roof but I mean at the station sort of
we
effectively but I mean it's just if the
image isn't it because it's kind of what
they wanted to make you feel like
obviously it is just a statue with a
tear as you say but the kind of a
Weeping Angel of the intra image is very
ominous yeah especially at a funeral
like a lot of people go to funerals and
just stand about crying and that's sort
of trying to look dignified in that
statues kind of summing that up and it's
very dignified but it's given a little
bit of emotion here yeah yeah yeah
definitely I guess the sort of the
falsities of experience as well as yeah
and you know we encounter a lot of the
real raw truths of the comedian and you
know we see throughout Watchmen it's you
know a very kind of avoid just straight
linear storytelling there's lots of
juxtaposition lots of multiple things
going on at once and I love the fact I
just think it's very playful on their
part that they mix the kind of just a
mother and daughter kind of bickering
with dark history but nothing too much
with a very kind of monotone kind of
somber funeral yeah I mean that the
issue opens on a funeral it's a bit like
a Batman V Superman II right right right
is it's like little slide dig their
hashtag Martha yeah yeah I've shagged
Martha why did she do it and so yes it's
a really good contrast you you kind of
get a New York contrasted with
California and and like stereotypically
New York's quite drab and raining a lot
and always that night and California's
like bright and sunny and but the
emotions that the people are given in
both are really negative and so it just
kind of shows that no matter where you
are you're probably upset about
something and there's lots of parallels
drawn between such as you know Laurie
having the flowers and then the flowers
also being present in the following
scene the same rare that's kind of you
know transmitted in between and I love
the look she make as many notes on these
first pages like the the last issue was
literally just jam-packed with them on
the first page whereas this seems kind
of
straightforward in a way like that there
are little things like Rorschach walking
by em I mean if you are reading this
issue-by-issue you probably wouldn't
pick up that that's the same guy from
the filmic and even if you did you
probably still wouldn't think all that
Rorschach you would just kind of think
this is just the world that they live in
but yeah that not a lot in these first
pages really goes on that there's like
of significance other than the Silk
Spectre past and present both argue and
they stand around at grave yeah yeah but
I mean do did you pick up anything there
was a few things oh yeah I agree
narrative lis there's nothing too much
there's a few things that kind of just
make me smile and question the logic of
the story for example I love how dr.
Manhattan is driven even though
obviously he can just teleport oil which
is a nice sort of I don't know it's kind
of obviously he's still a government
kind of operative at this point to a
certain extent so I guess and he's
wearing a suit as well which is none of
quite quite cool to be seen but yeah
just little things like I always like
the way Dave Gibbons is such an
intelligent illustrator in the sense
where we see in a second panelist alger
issue which is obviously Adrian eyes
kind of thing and then in the fourth
panel the sort of the N is upside down
because we're seeing it from a different
angle and it's just the way it plays
with space is excellent as well and you
know one of the things that I always
notice as well about you know the older
Silk Spectre she's pretty old like you
know they they did not kind of she's not
ugly but she's calling you know she's
got Sparky white hair yeah it should go
really oh look yeah we would be hoping
it it is kind of at the time you suppose
you'd never ever seen and retired
superhero I mean I kind of covered it in
the last issue but superheroes at the
time were immortalized in comics and
Superman was always thirty years old
Batman was always thirty years old and
to see that you know they've had this
life and they're now just some old
decrepit person sitting waiting to die
in a retirement home
kind of almost humbling in a way sort of
out of the norm like if you are hit with
the realization that if people were to
do this in real life eventually if they
lived long enough they would get to a
point where they were pretty much
useless and weren't able to offer
anything to society really like the used
to and obviously they would be so
reminiscent like one of the key
characteristics of Silk Spectre senior
is that she literally talks about the
past non-stop and she never talks about
anything nothing like what the even
she's even went so far to the point that
she she got raped yeah and she's looking
back on it fondly I know that this woman
has nothing to look forward to she even
says like the future looks darker and
darker every day whereas the past even
the I'm paraphrase yeah you get dark
stuff in the past I get brighter so it's
kind of a bit of a I don't know it's a
bit shock in the seed an old person and
then obviously Frank Miller actor this
would go on to do the Dark Knight
Returns which deals with an older Batman
but this was really innovative at the
time and it is kind of jarring to see
that these heroes of all old of just
turned and like bags of mush basically
yeah yeah I mean you know we had Hollis
the visit before we're down in the first
issue and obviously Hollis and Silk
Spectre seeing you will speak you know
in a later issue I believe when hot guys
I think so and it again he uses the
east-west paradigm to sort of constrict
their their fortunes but ya know it is
mad where she says poor Eddie you know
and then yeah you know Laurie's like how
can you even say that and you know four
years ago them so and that's one of the
things that you really got a gauge with
Watchmen I think and I try to keep
someone reading the Minutemen story but
this takes place over four decades like
it's quite long like the Minutemen were
together for ten years
like there's a lot of kind of history
that sometimes it can feel quite
yesterday and yesteryear but as a very
generational thing yeah definitely
and other a Silk Spectre and night I
will be only to survive and members of
the minute and yes I figure I think the
marks muff managing like a madhouse but
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so this
kind of the two surviving members of
both like yeah just not doing too well
not an interesting thing I've just kind
of noticed that in the bottom right
panel when Eddie's kept coffins getting
carried and everyone other than dr.
Manhattan's looking at it and yeah and I
was dr. Manhattan's just looking up but
he doesn't really care most in there for
ceremony and that kind of ties into a
lot of the things that are mentioned in
this issue and later in the book am
saying that dr. Manhattan's lost his his
care is caring and understanding for
Humanity and I mean even if you look on
page three unarmed just getting a bit
pet but he's the only one not looking at
the kauffman as well and so it just
seems like he's there for the sake of be
in there yeah and which kind of ties
into him getting driven there and it's
just kind of like he's appeared to be
there because the government have said
yeah we need to you at this funeral
mmm-hmm yeah no you're right actually
cuz that image on page three initially
wasn't sure how to read it is it him
kind of feeling like somber and you know
remorseful but I think you're right
actually you can see that he is just
detached you know in the sense of
ceremony because obviously to him death
isn't this kind of final thing in it
certainly a molecular sense another
thing that I like from the bottom right
panel you see it more clearly on the
later panels of the funeral Adrian
Adrian has like a guy with an umbrella
and a little like like for like you know
I mean he had a butler yeah like
carrying with the V on his hat
you can also yeah and you can also see
Moloch generous item with the roses I
mean that kind of ties into the issue
later but sheds quiet you know I didn't
make notes on it but actually sitting
and going through the book very slowly
there are a lot of things that are kind
of a stand out and jump out
I always remember reading this daredevil
story years ago I think it's called like
Guardian devil or something very like
gets this baby and I so I protected some
[ __ ]
there was a scene in it where it was a
one-page panel where it's like a funeral
and it was like the Marvel Universe
attend this funeral and you saw like you
know Doctor Strange of the front and
then in the back you can see like
silhouette season everything [ __ ] it's a
shame really but I understand that it's
a very tight storytelling the comedian's
funeral we literally see who we need to
see would it be because you've got to
think who would attend the funeral of
this like maverick diplomat you know
terrorists yeah exactly and it's only
the people who knew them and perhaps saw
some good in him at some point that of
them made in attendance because there's
absolutely there's definitely no women
there and like like so expect it I don't
I'm gonna spoil it
anyway comedian is so expect as father
and the fact that she's not even
attended obviously here but still and
the fact that Silk Spectre senior hasn't
told her that the comedians her father
it's kind of I don't know what to put
him to it's one of those things I think
Silk Spectre will look back on and think
oh maybe the comedian wasn't that bad of
a guy and I probably should have
attended his funeral hmm and much in the
same way that I'm mother's doing
yeah yeah completely this quite donk
which is doesn't reveal it knowing that
he's died as well which is kind of a
normal point in like soaps like if
someone dies like always your father
like that but it's like yeah not you
know there's nothing really put across
there and getting into like the later
panels I like again there's no kind of
sanctity like not to be too graphic but
you know you see silk spectres kind of
old wrinkly bosoms in her inner garment
you know it out of it just it there's no
hairs and graces yeah definitely not pin
it's really kind of shocking for the
time and then they do something later on
that kind of also is a bit oh they're
the Bible the Tijuana Bible which yet I
mean obviously labeled real you know
that they were they know physician I'm
sure
remain really oh yeah I'm sure see one
in American our Astoria are they have
been season 2 which anyway back to the
point it's obviously a female comic book
characters I mean you just have to look
at some of them like Super Girl Power
Girl feel feel there are objects like
sex objects and they're often drawn in a
way that is very sexualized
I mean if you google a lot of the stuff
that Robb Liefeld's done and all of his
women massive massive bosoms and massive
asses stick thin waist and but no one
ever like publicly says all female comic
book characters are sex objects until
Silk Spectre herself points out that she
was used in a pornographic comic book at
one point and so it's quite interesting
to see that really like cemented as yeah
I was a sex object back then and people
could do drawings of me I'm accepting of
that and I loved it yeah yes I know it
was it was it was all part of it in it
again in the sense of comedians attack
as well it was all part this subjugation
that is kind of willingly effective and
just to just a little quick bit of
history for Wikipedia Tijuana Bibles
also known as eight pages Tilian
MacBooks jigs and maggie books jojo book
floozies grey banks and two-by-fours
were palm-sized porno comics producing
the u.s. from the 1920s to the early
1960s their popularity peaked during the
Great Depression era so I love you know
Alan Moore is obsessed with comic
history and a certain extent and he's so
knowledgeable I love that he brings
these in and they're like you know a
real application of the world yeah
exactly it's quite strange to imagine
these actually knocking about you ham
these days but like a lot of people
probably under them for them for the
fact that there was so famous and when
they're used in TV shows I mean in
American Horror Story it's basically a
German
concentration camp dr. who who has one
knocking about and he it's not like ever
highlighted it's just a prostitute going
through his drawers and she sees a lot
of pictures of bondage and one of a
Tijuana Bible as well so it's quite kind
of it's very much of its time and and it
once again like surmises that so expect
a senior no matter how bad it was in the
past always looks back on it fondly like
there's people who've been drawn
pictures of a nude having sex with
people and she's looking back on it
smiling thinking yet their mother days
and we get quite a powerful panel on the
third page of just you know the three of
them in front of the flag being folded
over his coffin
you know it's brilliant like it's very
effective and I love the rain hitting
the nameplate in that splash yeah it's
really really good and a lot of times up
like this is a really grounded depiction
of a funeral like a lot of times in
comics you would at least get the
feeling that the spirit had traveled up
in heaven at some point and maybe they
were at the end of the funeral the Sun
would come out and someone would look up
into the sky a sunray would come down
and shine you know what I mean to make
you feel like oh maybe this you know
he's died but maybe that there's
something that's happened here that was
good overall
whereas here after the funeral it's
still raining it's still dark everyone
looks sad the shake hands and they leave
and there's no kind of feeling of
closure it's just like yeah the guy's
dead that's it and it's just a wonderful
kind of the disparity of dr. Manhattan
standing there as well like if he wasn't
there they'd seen no one questioned it
as being like fantasy but it's just yes
was the imposing of him they're just
really kind of relegated to this you
know you know majestic kind of
imagination and here we have as well
yeah a Silk Spectre in that page while
recounting the minute
who were left so Hollis Mason and Byron
Lewis who is you know Mothman who you
know for all intents and purposes is
kind of lost like we see later that when
when they meet Dhoni they comes around
with Hollis Mason for drinking some
flashback and we see him kind of
struggling to get into his sanity so it
and it's odd as well with the name the
comedian
you know Silk Spectre finds the need to
do at the end of page free there's also
like in page one so I guess he finally
reach the punchline so he was a comedian
he always forty get to the last lap it's
like it's weird that people need to take
this moment to kind of pawn off his name
and kind of make a joke yeah yeah this
kinda strange like know this issue kind
of explains exactly why he is called the
comedian as well and because they say
that you saw America's true face and
kind of parody it so parodied it and
which is true I mean America's known
pearl doing a lot of bad things like
Vietnam and obviously you know a lot of
soldiers were going over there and a lot
of innocent children and women were
getting killed in this conflict and the
fact that the comedian does that it is
sort of a satire of America mmm I mean I
don't want to say Americans are rapists
right I know I've never really yeah like
you know comedian is America I can kinda
see the argument is if the dark side of
America yeah yeah eggs laughing it up
like Donald Trump can stand on a podium
and say that all Mexicans are rapists
and get you know appointed president and
whereas yeah I'm sure the statistics are
probably just as high in America and
it's sort of this thing that you you
laugh and alienate the other and but you
won't kind of you know it's a joke when
you do it like the comedian does so many
bad things and he attack is like this
friendly fire there's their dictatorship
almost and it's kind of yeah uses the
satire of what the rest of the world
kind of views America as but he seems to
be in on the joke whereas everyone else
kind of isn't
yeah definitely and the fact that he was
kind of drafted in by the government
after the Keene Act shows that you know
they would they would somebody's there
and we kind of close up with the you
know the Silk Spectre section with the
Tijuana Bible gets given as well you
know and just to talk about it was said
by someone who's been sending a letters
you know a fan so the seal this kind of
I guess in a certain sense you know you
have comic-con dog you and you know fans
like they give signatures and stuff like
that it's kind of that still even in
this world there's a certain admiration
for these you know super and stuff but
we go back and arguably a little
flashback because we get your camera you
know and then kind of going back and you
know our first real taste of this scene
that we've seen a lot of in you know
photos in the first issue which is
really exciting going back to the minute
myself I love all of these sort of stuff
in the book man I love seeing these guys
together yeah absolutely great and the
fact that kind of using it is publicity
as well yeah and I've just noticed the
newspaper headline that scientists make
first artificial yeah element lutonium
and which that's kind of highlighting
the time you've also got the clock in
the bottom corner yeah yeah 1940 and so
that like signifies exactly when it is
and it is just great to see how these
superheroes started out but it goes dog
very quickly yeah I mean yeah it's like
literally in a page if you look at the
passage that okay so we get the
flashback in the last page on page five
oh there's a Minutemen being the top
right or top left and then the bottom
right is all [ __ ] you know we know
what's going to happen next
yeah other thing and you know we have
Eddie we have the comedian him trying to
say like let me see if I can fish them
out for you the spots in the eyes like
that's quite a menacing thing to say
even as a kind of flood you think like
fishing somewhere always yeah there is
kind of a sinister thing yes feeling to
it straight away another thing that I am
not quite too sure but they do it twice
in this issue and I don't know what is
called the basically the black head
where silhouette silhouette thank you
she says shoot
she heavily implies that Sully is polish
and which Sully to put her like denied
straightaway AB which I don't know I'm
guessing that was a part of the times
but it's then later followed up with
Moloch and when Rorschach's
interrogating him he basically says
Edgar William Jacobi also known as Edgar
William Vaughn also known as Edgar
William ed gab right also known as
Moloch and the first name Edgar William
Jacobi I'm guessing that's polish as
well hmm and it the fact that you
changed his name when he was polish and
the fact that so Jupiter changed her
name to Vita I don't know what it was
originally it's not a very good err
research that I've done mmm so good
given my mind but dead it's something
similar at Jupiter but sounds polish and
I don't want to be racist and throwing
things around like Jupiter Rishikesh
right right right right I don't do that
it's there it's there for the devil to
see but it kind of shows that at the
time a lot of Polish immigrants were
coming over to America and then trying
to blend in as much as possible by
changing their names and it does let us
know that we are living in this world
where the world is accepting of other
cultures and stuff like that yeah which
so again sort of highlights the
comedians and morality and intentions
and the way that you acts throughout
this issue it's very clear that America
was quite racist and xenophobic in the
comedian sort of cements that and the
fact that we've got someone denying that
they're polish well two people denying
that the Polish and could kind of you
know it and courses that point very
subtly but by doing really much on it
mmm yeah yeah I think I think definitely
you know Silk Spectre jr. makes a lot of
reference to the Polish nature as well I
think your first issue as well and
there's lots of stuff in just this
opening panel the page 5 because
obviously the first time we really see
the Minutemen not just posed
and I like as well where you know what
is mr. owl which is quite sort of I
guess it was humoring him dressers it's
not saying night hour like that you
would say mr. back to Batman would you
call him Batman so yeah it's kind of a
little in front but that eight prints
they'll be ready in a week so obviously
technology you know we're far from dr.
Manhattan like got away seems to be
developed and and that's probably why
everyone's got this photograph like
obviously yeah the NIH email know that
there was an attempted rape after it and
so probably not one like have that on
their mantelpiece but because of the
time yeah the the proper use that fo
because obviously they paid for it it
takes a week to get developed there's
only going to be eight prints of it and
which is quite strange cos is more than
another is eight members there is eight
yeah there is year and generally said
something stupid there let's um let's go
through from left to right quickly on
the what we think the costumes of last
year's winner says what do you think of
mouth map ridiculous costume level it's
literally a more physically these giant
buggy wings and even as the sort of the
antenna I for some reason emotional yeah
I like I you you see Batman in the comic
and you think my eyes costumes really
good and this is it but you think if
anyone ever wore that in real life you
just be like you look like a complete
idiot and and mock man obviously thinks
he looks like a moth but he looks like
complete absolute idiot yeah it looks
like he looks like a goon definitely and
he's weird you can see like when they're
coming through the door in the next
panel you can just like Gore P and
awkward them yeah
dollar bill a bit more traditional I
guess yeah it sort of got a Captain
America cross with Superman look to it
yeah
and it's got the stars on it and it's
blue and red and yeah it's kind of more
the traditional costume yeah yeah be
captain metropolis as well is kind of
again but it has what a lot of super
bosses at the time the sort of the semi
mask which likes your hair to come out
yeah it's got like a mane
now yeah yeah comedian comedian yeah
compare like what he would go underwear
this is really ludicrous like you've got
a belt with like a smile and yeah yeah
it's got like red clown but like a
jester more than lawyer at all yeah it's
very garish I think it's almost going
for that sort of early 50s kind of you
know I look quite dated like yeah Sally
Jupiter's costume just it's not even
like a superhero Konami I don't really
know what it's giving us with stockings
typed it might be some comment on sort
of the disposability in the air that
time followed the see do what adjust is
I think it looks cheap but it's kind of
cool with all the ropes yeah yeah it's
like hangman costume it sort of reminds
me a bit of the Scarecrow mmm this masks
very like dark and intimidate and as I'm
guessing this is kind of the Batman
parody where is dollar bills sort of the
did Superman parody yeah you know yeah
the meeting kind of looks a bit like
Robin yes yeah that's fair yeah night
owl for me I love these feathered pants
yeah like he's so got the pants that
Robin would wear yeah in the 40s
all the costumes are kind of taking
elements from existing superheroes
except for silhouette where she's
literally looks like a teacher or a
French artist
yeah silhouette one's the Lisa hero one
yeah you could you could probably get
away with just we're not in the street
you know one would say oh there's a
that's true that's right - yeah that's
almost like an altar costume like which
is in a normal day job yeah nonetheless
really cool thing and I like when we go
into the main room we see like Moss
man's like name on the desk
yeah cute they've obviously had a
meeting yet you know they've agreed
they've had the photograph everyone's
having a great time it's all fancy it's
all gonna feel like they're gonna do
something then Sally goes to get changed
and it all kicks off well it's just dark
because we have sort of them arguing
amongst themselves really about ways you
know going
forward for the team and they will agree
to go back to the owls nest for a beer
which yeah you know very good of him but
then we get the for me the genius
paneling going into the angle water
change from behind where she still got
her yellow on and then yeah now she's
into her undergarments and that high
that hangs suspended very ominous yeah
yeah it's just I really just well put
together and drawn-out and it is like
you do get an atmospheric feeling of
tension amps also in the background you
can see Moloch's solar mirror one yen
and which at the time when this was
going on the forties in comics even up
to like a DS all of the the
supervillains had some ludicrous weapon
nightly like using diamonds to power a
laser on the moon that would shoot down
earth and it was all stuff like that so
the fact that they confiscate is a
weapon like that allegedly but hanging
around in the background kind of speaks
subtly to the what was going on in
comics at the time but it sort of just
opposed by this ludicrousness of course
so like this absolute like horrific rape
where comedians like punched her in the
stomach yeah yeah there in the face
blood dripping out of her mouth when
she's on the ground this there's
something that I realized looking back
at his scenes which I mean I don't mean
it in a weird way but these are some of
my favorite scenes of what's financially
JP there's oh like all that awful yeah
with the ordinary yeah yeah and an
Orthodox and you not expected pick up a
comic I mean the comics were written for
kids yeah and if you your parents like
in 1995 went down to a comic book shop
and seen this and thought I'll get that
for little Timmy because all kids at the
time were called Timmy yeah and it's a
very popular name for children because
to grow out of there once a hit 12
anyway I digress
so yeah you think artists coming up pick
it up for my my son he likes button on
the TV with Adam West on
you I'll pick up this one for them all
what you did what you reading that to me
I just in it - there's a man raping a
woman oh well I hope Batman jumps in and
stops that man from raping that woman no
no the man raping the woman is the
superhero
oh right get that out your hands now
well I mean the thing is and its core
fundamentals the superhero narrative is
pretty much as follows
like man attacks helpless woman or child
and super hero enters to save it and
you're right this archetype of
superheroism has infiltrated us but you
know the initial meeting of this group
with ranks itself it's to play out in
the room it's just it's heartbreaking
yeah and it's quote the kind of speech
that is how like weak the team was yeah
for the fact that this goes on and they
still let them in
yeah the Minutemen they're like don't
cast them out and it's like very it's
very hard to kind of determine exactly
what it means it just kind of shows that
you know these superheroes maybe they
weren't like Rorschach who is just black
and white like if he seen it like this
going on he would have killed the person
whereas these are like yeah it happened
one so I'll let you off this time and
it's very strange to kind of see that
these are meant to be protected and that
letting members their group do this and
it's probably how comedian managed to
ascend so far and in the ranks of
society because people were willing to
just turn a blind eye to what he did and
sort of what he can do Stanley effect
that you know he is a he's a not super
hero but you know he's a hero quite a
costumed hero he has he's brilliant of
fighting people
so of course he'd be able to subdue
Sally easily I mean it's dark to think
about but it's truly imagine if Batman
wanted to rape someone he could quite
easily yeah they're kind of like it's
that it's just showing you is bad if
power corrupts and it's the physicality
as while he smacks her in the mouth you
smash the head on the floor and then
you see him grabbing for his belt buckle
and the hairs on his ass in the next way
it's just yeah it's gruesome yeah and
it's like talking back to the whole how
comedian is like a satire of satire of
America
maybe hooded justice is also like you
know a satire of England and the UK and
the rest of the world like America has
committed quite a lot of atrocities and
but because we're so relying on them
they are sort of an ally we always look
the other way and and I'm guessing that
sort of what the Minutemen really are a
metaphor of like they've got this guy in
the ranks who it is definitely a satire
of America he's going around doing these
horrible things but you know he does
good once in a while so we you know we
let him off he he helps us and it I
don't only get too political but I'm
guessing that's what that's what of
going for yeah yeah and we see you know
as if lots of Watchmen stuff lots of
great background stuff for instance King
mobs eight masks which you see kind of
looking on this horrific gorillas snow
which Evans bodies that you know brutal
masochism that the comedian at uh dogs
he's even leaning against it when he
starts talking to her and it's just his
language is so awful like what the hell
were you doing here I knew I was
changing and he's like sure I did you
announced it loud enough like oh well
creep yeah yeah no you hate it he's
totally read the situation yeah I mean
yeah but he doesn't even said no he goes
no spelled ye yeah yeah yeah he's very
forceful um yeah and it's just not a
nice kind of scene hell no no and then
how did was early justice comes in beats
you know idiot really badly says he's
going to break his neck and stuff which
is pretty full on but then he stops and
I love how for the first time in the
series we see honey just his actual eyes
not the colored sort of shade yeah and
it looks very angry it's a very well
drawn like even though he's got a
massive mask in front of them you can
tell exactly what
facial expressions yeah yeah it's the
penetrators lots of close-ups and I love
especially where she scratches Eddie and
then he pauses when you say like Eddie
doll use no he's going to unleash now
yeah exactly yeah and just a little sort
of thing you also got the clock and I
had e4 Eddie's walking out the room that
five to twelve and which is obviously a
repeating theme throughout Watchmen and
then on the next page you saw got the
purchase line there yeah and eaten like
it like looking horrendous blood
dripping from my mouth like he's really
hot like a waffle you just get up and
for God's sake cover yourself yeah and
cover obviously sort of them they
obviously they covered this up yeah and
the public didn't find out about it till
the release of under the Red Hood yeah
so it's sort of also means like recover
yourself and also this is going to be
covered up when they were going to speak
about this again yeah I wonder how it
was covered up because I don't know if
you learn this in before Watchmen bottom
read that book I wonder how night out
found out obviously would have just seen
her really I'll put two and two together
but yeah that's detailed but I love the
Tijuana by was always like oh say baby
this is tops and like yes quite so they
went from a rape scene yeah yeah yeah of
pornographic one yeah it's bad yeah sir
very brave and then you know you sort of
see her fingernail on the book and then
she casts it down and then obviously you
know what is she looking at Sally she's
looking at the old picture yet again she
must have looked at this picture a
thousand times
yeah it's probably we live that rape a
thousand times and but yeah it it is
kind of weird oh you just went from a
rape scene in a comic to then her
reading like a pornographic scene in the
comic and it's very very like there's a
complete dichotomy between the two and
it's yeah it's not it's not lost on me
no no certainly not and I mean Sally has
quiet quite a brutal line actually
saying you know at least I don't sleep
with a h-bomb yeah why I sauce
you know it's quite quite sort of piece
of one I've got to think as well like
however long dr. manhattan's been going
at this point maybe a few decades
whatever at least decades like is he
really like still attached to humanity
through her or he must have been
chipping away for years
yeah hundred percent I mean the
government have absolutely no idea what
to do with the guy and the take them to
this funeral and he clearly doesn't care
or want to be there and and they just ya
the government's lost complete touch of
the whole situation and I think that by
having and so expect her there to sleep
with them that it was going to stay
loyal to the country and but yeah just
[Music]
and we transition into Ozymandias which
I really like when we go back in time
here we sort of Zulia in space that his
faith hasn't changed yet he's not really
aged know that he's meant to be immortal
as well I think right now not it's done
things I mentioned in the comics place
and fit that I'm sure read a Wikipedia
article once saying that he was a
Centurion also been alive for over 100
years and ya know I quickly you keep
talking and I'll have a look yeah well
again I want to focus on you know we
have the second we had before the second
team we meet now the crimebusters which
are the kind of you know ancestral
legacy of the Minutemen of course and
again we have all the costumed
adventurers here and it might be worth
us going for I mean the first person of
interest obviously comedian who I love
we know it's him we can sort of
recognize the outfit stuff but not only
easy in a chair not only is he got his
feet up on the table and he's smoking
and he's reading a paper
he's burping as well yeah and his his
costumes I completely changed and from
1941 to like the gritty atheist costume
um yeah it's just a complete change
whereas that guy is still in that same
costume doing the same talk he's a lot
older his head you know his hairline is
receding
his belly's a lot me right yeah yeah
it's just not he's not
doin the best nothing with wrister times
no not at all when I mean would you
think of Ozzy's costume
yes all right no it's a bit flamboyant
put definitely a is its kind of big
shoulder pads draped over things
I'm just looking at God's man Deus now
and there isn't anywhere saying that
he's a Centurion so yeah I wasn't sure
if you'd a stick there but I didn't want
to question you
yeah don't don't question me just let me
run wild
I'm the comedian and this product is
obviously please don't do any big
similar to him oh well and we see a
Rorschach and night out who kind of look
like we've seen him before really yeah
it's a big boy dear and he speaks a bit
more logical in this yes the Rorschach a
big interesting thing that Russia has in
this comic is his speech bubbles are
completely normal and he talks in full
sentences obviously this is before like
the whole thing that broke him and so
he's quite a grounded person back then
he has really witnessed the true horrors
of crime fighting and so he's still
normal he's not jaded by anything and
he's just he's just enjoying life he's
got his nice little scarf on and he's
just having a great time with his best
mates there's also a little clock in
this room as well I don't know if it's 5
2 or 10 to 12 but you know what I'm
saying
their clock things carrying over there
having them eaten at the same time yeah
yeah exactly
very very at least no one gets right at
this me no one no one does I mean this
is kind of a telling image as ever you
know we have sort of denial of Rorschach
are kind of interested in it as is Janey
Slater boxing dr. Manhattan and Laurie
are you know checking each other out and
sort of Ozzy sort of you know standing
holding core and yeah I like I love the
storytelling on the next page on the
page 10 with the free panels at the top
where you have you know it's comedians
sprawled out in front of all three yeah
exactly these in every panel and it's
quite strange that they broke it up
like this but it is a really nice effect
and and you can seem read in the paper
which says dr. Manhattan an imperialist
weapon and some ik Russians I'm guessing
it says oh by yeah by Russians or by
Russians and yes it's kinda straight to
see that he's having a meeting with them
and he's also reading a paper
Hahnemann you can sort of see that it's
reading something about dick which I'm
guessing is them yeah Nixon : yes yes
route yeah but it's just yeah he's just
great sense of motion watching it kind
of the way that he transitions from each
panel to panel and the sense of shock on
captain metropolis is face you know and
in fact he's holding the word drugs kind
of disembodied there you know kind of
half before he's putting it on there and
yeah and then Rorschach as well but this
is an up washout was like obviously I
agree but a group that this size he's
more like a publicity exercise so now
it's getting big and unwieldy which is
exactly what the first one was complete
publicity exercise but obviously
comedians been through all that before
he knows exactly how it's going to go
and that's why it's just not really
paying attention to it it's just kind of
showing up to this meeting to be as
negative as possible and just to tell
captain metropolis home which overs time
that he's wasting and how ridiculous it
is that he thinks vigilantes can make
difference in this world
and comedian faces off with Ozzie as
well I love that I love that panel the
bottom left where the comedians are
lecturing Ozzie and it's kind of sitting
down yeah look it looks great with all
the characters behind looking quite
embarrassed and shame yeah I think it
doesn't handle really like anything
everyone else looks a bit annoyed yeah
dr. Manhattan's just kind of he's in the
exact same like position that he is yeah
I mean he's just standing still which is
a complete like and it signifies exactly
what his character is he's just always
standing still because he's not moving
through time at all it's just existing
and the fact that he's not moving at all
he's not really engaged in the
conversation it's just there it's just
present which is sort of similar to how
he is at the funeral
and we get a taste of Ozymandias grand
plan as well
when chameleon color confronted with
what would you do and it already takes a
little intelligence yet and then you set
the the world on fire
yeah which sort of gives Ozymandias the
idea of it because you can see him at
the bottom looking at the map and it's
all burnt new realizes yet this guy is
right the world is going to go hell it
need killer wet and Stocking news so
I've got to think of something to do and
in a sense because that part of the map
survives you know it's about sort of
obliterating one part to kind of
maintain a whole with them I was reading
apparently by the way Alan Moore
discovered like late into writing that
the sort of odd human dies his plan was
part of Lux from 50s TV show episode it
was very similar like scientists faked a
nuclear attack to sort of convince the
world to stop you know warring I think
he had knowledge it or something in the
book somehow so it's quite good so but
but yeah I love again we see doctor we
see the comedian in a doorway leaving
and you know the first time I was here
trying to rape someone this time he
destroys this you know well he'll plan
and it's quite fun as well to see like
some of the things that captain
metropolis put in it promiscuity and
black unrest yeah which is just
hilarious yeah just quite roses up again
with the whole head and polish people
that is what black and rest means isn't
it yeah yeah give something for you're
colorblind mind I'm sure I'm sure yeah
yeah um and you know you know also like
you've got a sort of a comedian to a
certain extent broy all upon himself in
his cruel irony by inspiring i've human
diets he then killed himself and sent
himself insane because of the plan yeah
yeah yeah that's quick good
I mean it's so well thought out like the
little sort of things just like the way
that human diet looks at the the map
it's just such a big payoff in the end
if looking at it on your first read you
wouldn't notice it at all you just think
I just either you probably would just
skim past that panel and just read the
speech bubbles
but it's so like significant to
basically the grand plan yeah yeah no
massively and we go back on the
following page well back to the funeral
I love that opens the sort of open top
shot looking around quite nice that the
folded flag the rain coming down
interesting you know it's very powerful
very evocative and again we get another
sort of flashback this time dr.
Manhattan although I guess you'll I'll
be dr. Manhattan is experiencing time at
once so it's never really a flashback
but you know for this comic narrative
perspective and it's a firework that
takes us back to him and comedian in the
bar which is another like amazing scene
yeah absolutely brilliant definitely one
understand that moments in the book yeah
like it's got the badge there the smiley
face badge you have very clearly
standing out on comedians uniform and
it's just a drab dreary bar that they're
standing in and after winning Vietnam I
mean dr. Manhattan pretty much won the
Vietnam War single-handedly and it's
comedian sort of narrating how he thinks
the the United States would have went
crazy had had they lost the Vietnam War
of course in losing the Vietnam War in
real life it sort of made Russia think
or perhaps they aren't as dangerous as
we think they are whereas if they had
won the Vietnam War in this way with a
walking talking super bomb obviously
like things are going to escalate in
Russia is going to think oh crap when
you really start making nuclear weapons
because this guy can just show up to a
country and win the war within a couple
of days and so it yeah it's probably
best that we don't have dr. Manhattan
and on earth because obviously the fear
that he commands would cause lot of
countries to really rally together to
fight the u.s. yeah and the the the
Nixon with the with the peace signs up
is actually a sort of play on quite a
famous scene when the last it was an
engineering is negative in real life it
was the last chopper out of Saigon or
something like that it's quite a famous
moment everyone's getting on the
helicopter
end but this obviously shows Nixon
casually walking year I just wonder you
can see MBC truck down below and the
flag and just you know everyone just
kind of it's a it's a publicity
opportunity rather than a rather than a
war zone mostly but obviously it's still
quite grim in the fact we're you know
Eddie's got someone pregnant and yet you
know they are here to solve and very
very painful scene yet again especially
she turns very quickly uptown she
confronts him she must know who he is
and then she goes to kill him or at
least maim him yeah I mean I think it's
because he's been putting these things
off but it's clearly important this off
for as long as possible she was wanting
to be talking to him for a while yeah
and obviously he's been saying oh yeah
after the war after the war and then
yeah she says yeah she realizes that
he's just gonna walk away from it and
she can't walk away from it so just
going to give him something to remember
here it's and when I loved seeing her
smash the wine bottle and the shards
kind of flying over him turning round
yeah and see the in the Gordon Jian
mirror kind of streak of reflection and
then when she cuts him which it's almost
like a sort of um you know anime scene
when you see him like it's got this
kinda like unreal nough Stu it's I guess
it's a reflection isn't it so
yeah the backgrounds all kind of like
and I'm a background like lots of quests
eyelid color with lots of lines coming
off it to kind of show the the way that
the bottle moved and a serious slash
across the face yeah she get some good
oh man
and we see the blood drip on the
Suwannee face and then he pulls for the
gun and there's the thing that I like
really buying a pack for his heart like
tears looking at McGann yeah he knows
what's gonna happen and I can't believe
it's escalated there she was meant to be
carrying his trail and he's still the
kind of person who would do this and dr.
Manhattan once again sort of he's very
similar to hooded justice he doesn't
really do anything overall to stop this
from going down except for this is when
from a rape which is what hooded justice
was there to witness to a murder
HM dr. Manhattan has and the book still
let him be in the Watchmen hmm yeah yeah
and you know he's actually comedians as
you watch me
you see literally were watching me do
this and you think you have no influence
on it at all
you could have changed a gun into steam
or the bullet and Qamar Curie or the
bottle into snowflakes yeah like you
know great great color line they're very
very powerful and this is a great scene
as well this whole section but kind of
just embodying both the characteristics
of these huge figures in the story and
you know comedian also has the foresight
you know you don't really give a damn
back human beings I've watched you you
never cared about what to name Jaime
Slayer even before you ditched her soon
you won't be interested in Sally
Jupiter's little girl either
and you're at a touch you're turning
into like god help us all and then we
see dr. Manhattan staring down and if
you notice he's disembodied through the
table
yeah and it's fair you look up when on
the top right panel is actually floating
above the ground slightly as well all
right so it's just kind of detached from
the whole scenario is just not really
like that involved in it and obviously
kept the comedian like confirms that he
doesn't care anymore
you turn the Newark flake and so yeah
it's quite it's clearly it's just
passing through this he's not actually
involved in it mm-hmm and it's kind of
it's it's Alan Moore that's putting to
the reader one of the most horrific
situations there was someone gunning
down someone that got pregnant you know
after cutting them across the face and
it's showing you how you know Manhattan
really doesn't really care like you know
you just see that there's no it's a same
pose that you striking all these years
later kind of thing that kind of just
sense of kind of trying to maybe face
some sort of attachment but not being
able to get yeah yeah exactly yeah and
it's just so well put together and you
just wouldn't expect to see this in a
comic once again no no that I mean that
continues here Watchmen but it really
this really is like a standout moment of
yeah this guy was a complete piece of
[ __ ] and probably deserved everything
that you got
and the club once again satire in
America because America and Vietnam
definitely killed lots of pregnant women
and and they just moved on from it and
it's kind of exactly fit some of the
soldier mentality here that the comedian
has that yeah these people aren't
American they're not actually real
people so I can treat them how I want
yeah
dr. Manhattan also kind of you know
maybe sees it the same way he accepts
what he doesn't see people as actual
anything at all
so the comedian doesn't see the Vietnam
as real people in Manhattan doesn't see
people at all yeah yeah yeah
and then the next panel we get the sort
of the Trivium of the three guys here
and you know perhaps you can read into
what said of the homily here after earth
over you know vitaes probably you know
he wants to save the earth I suppose in
some sort of sense ashes to ashes could
symbolize perhaps dr. Manhattan you know
his Genesis like because he was
integrating into ashes and then dust to
dust as we've seen you know on Archie on
you know night hours equipment him as a
person in the sense is what yes see you
know and it's all about the death of the
costumed hero really earth earth ashes
to ashes because now we have what sort
of happens after this meeting you know
the true terror of the street and
comedian would be [ __ ] mask yeah it's
very strange they got this costume now
and but yeah I don't really know what to
make of it too much it just seems to be
like very domineering
and obviously that plays in there
exactly what the Watchmen are in the
scene where he is so this figure that
just completely dominating these people
doesn't care what he's doing to them
it's it's very sadomasochistic and it's
just seeing archie in these figures all
these piercing eyes coming out everyone
rioting below like this is one of those
pages you can really pour over there's
so much detail at the bottom
yeah it's just incredible like must have
taken so long to map out and draw and
there's so much stuff going on and it's
sort of America attacking in my first
America and like there's something that
you just wouldn't see in comics like my
son is a police officer you [ __ ] yeah
yeah the police not wanting the watch
mentor exist which really juxtaposes how
police were at the time in comics like
they were happy to work with Batman it's
just completely the opposite to that yes
and just really showing you yet again
the reality of what would happen if
superheroes are around of course there
would be this friction between the
establishment and you know what they are
and vigilantism would throw everything
into disrepute so I love seeing it I
love seeing you know probably for
comedian this is no different than
Vietnam now definitely not it's just
always fight in a war and this is just
another war to him it just so happens to
take place in America yeah just going
through as well the sort of I love him
throwing that grenade and I can I ask um
you know be really polite like I'm sorry
for being ever less than it and the
grenade and it's like between everyone's
faces or like you're looking at it and
screaming yeah it's crazy it just a guy
just doesn't care no night I'll still
trying to be a good person and once
again it's someone seeing the comedian
do something really bad and not really
lifting a finger to stop it yeah yeah
yeah and comedian mentions the
government contra and you know that new
axe is being held in through the Keene
act and you can also see the kind of the
tear splatter on Archie with the sort of
mud on the bottom yeah yeah yeah I've
never really noticed that before we hear
you completely right yeah it's also
almost like these inanimate objects are
crying throughout the entire comic yeah
yeah just the interesting motif that
comes through and I love seeing these
guys together now I don't know if I'm
reading into this too much to stop me
but on the page 18
so the fourth panel where comedians
firing the gun I can almost see a smiley
face
this is enough yeah I think you're
completely right but Abbi I mean who
knows but yet again we have who watches
to watch more but we don't really ever
get to see in full which I love
yeah so you all it's for the same with
the newspaper headlines you're always
kind of reading between the lines of it
and making up for yourself and I mean as
if to prove our whole theory of comedian
be in America he does say what Lord no
out says wow the American dream he says
it came true you're looking at it yeah
damn exactly okay all right
yeah all right it's a very badass kind
of almost non watch many saw online but
for the comedian it works yeah 100% it's
it's very much like yeah what else did
you think was going to happen if he gave
complete power to a country yeah like
absolute power corrupts absolutely and
that's kind of what's happened here and
you know Dan now at the funeral as well
in the flashback obviously as we just
seen they've had some times together him
in the community wasn't just Walsh I can
deny al you know they would fight
together in pairs as well and him
throwing the badge down along with the
flag I mean very symbolic a hundred
percent and it is that is sort of the
end of the comedian and it's very
similar to the way I let the comedians
throw another window no I'm saying I
love that yeah yeah I guess you've
actually I didn't consider that but
that's a good point yeah the and I love
how you see the face of the smile like
looking down it falls into the you know
it's a very characteristically brilliant
and the shaking hands as well from
Manhattan and aid Adrian where there
cufflinks as well yeah oh yeah brilliant
here so they've both got like signature
cufflinks and we got we go from the
cufflinks of them to the kind of raggedy
gloves of Rorschach watching on yeah as
Moloch walk though yeah just come to
pays respects but he's actually easy to
be the only one that's really interested
in like paying his respects that you'd
bring in a massive bunch of flowers mmm
curtain or one else has the world is
kind of showed up and tonight I showed
up and threw a badge
but that was about it
and no one else ever kind of showed them
respect which is strange because Moloch
was obviously I mean they hinted at a
superweapon early on and the issue
he was obviously quite a big flow for
the comedian and so yes it's it's like
really just stutter it is kind of what I
imagined would happen like obviously
comes from a battle rap background you
do respect your opponents quite a lot
right right and when when you compete it
against someone and then it's all over
and you're both kind of left after it
you do have a certain amount of respect
for them because you've been through the
same battle together and and which is
exactly what's happened here Moloch and
the comedian have been through the same
battles together and so they do have a
lot of respect and admiration for each
other probably which is rise actually
brought these roses along whereas the
other people attending the funeral
probably didn't have any admiration for
the comedian and that's kind of clear by
the way that they remember him and we
get to Moloch returning home we can call
sort of sword down the last issue to him
kind of going back and Rorschach having
broken in you know being there to kind
of suggest it like him sort of chilling
in the fridge is quite a inventive
soright ambush yeah like really good
completely just jumps out of the scene
as well in the same way that Rorschach
jumps out the fridge like it's very
somewhere and calm and you know there's
not any dialog and and then he just
jumps out and he leaps it leaps out the
page almost them and just grabs your
attention straight away and it is
strange once again seeing someone who's
had this life and now reduced to a
crappy life after their career as a
super villain yeah yeah yeah there's no
no's or glory is for any of these
characters who seems we see in his kind
of trash as well like pizzas and ice
cream and you know it's a sort of I
don't know what that really says about
it but you know what I mean it's not
kind of a luxurious life by anyway it's
not it's not house Pro because probably
no one's going to come
round and visit told ya
Angie Faria the way the way Moloch is
you know the fear in his face constantly
like you look at all Britt which nine of
these panels he's being hassled by
Rorschach in some way physically you
know holding provide and the way the
bottom so the eighth panel hit these
eyes I just like solely so scared oh
yeah absolutely terrified like he knows
what Rorschach's like and he obviously
knows that he's a massive supervillain
and he thinks yeah this guy's gonna kill
me mmhmm yeah yeah and it's just kind of
tragic isn't it as well that comedian
who you know seeing quite successful his
life but never had any real
relationships he goes to Moloch like his
old yoke exactly in that kind ties back
into the respect and admiration thing
and you can only relate to people who've
been through similar things to what you
have and Moloch is obviously one of the
only people that can sort of see it from
his perspective like whilst the comedian
was labeled a hero he very much was a
villain and and Moloch was a villain and
he's it's probably the only person I can
connect to in the world um he obviously
can't connect to other people in the
Watchmen because they have different
morals to him and whereas Moloch's at
one point we're probably quite similar
mm-hm and this whole sequence here these
kind of final pages is you know kind of
recapping comedians visit to Moloch
revealing like I always felt then if you
felt this step I don't know this animal
just having fun but it's quite
coincidental the comedian like finds a
list with people's names on it and it's
all very very sixties Batman asked in a
sense yeah I was actually reading a
Batman comic from a website definition
of Kodo UK where read through all of the
Batman graphic novels in chronological
order no stop and it should kind of see
exactly how they are and at review them
make sure you go definition of color you
came and and there is an issue where
Batman's investigating mr. freeze and
any finds his hideout I don't know how
he finds it but it just shows up mr.
Freeze's out murdering people and and he
finds a list
of names two of them are crossed out who
were the two people murdered earlier in
that issue he's got two names at the
bottom and with a big one saying he's
next written next to the year the the
one that he's trying to murder at the
time so he tracks him down he stops them
and that is kind of yeah that's exactly
the same really here he's found a list
of names you sort of got in on the plan
and he wants to he wants to get out and
stop it yeah and just so much of what
comedians confessing here use crying in
a certain extent on the foot of this bed
yeah saying you know I shot kids in Nam
I've done bad things to women I've never
done anything like this it's like almost
kind of reason with himself what you
have done some absolute atrocities
comedian like a little bit but this well
no they want as far as it but III wonder
how can we be like that I don't know I
mean that I mean like comedians so yeah
yeah bad things but yeah I can justify
them which year he's gokon really but I
wonder I I always want to what it
thought it had a comedian discovered he
[ __ ] like did he see a monster and think
all that's going to destroy New York
like and what he mentions saying I
should have never looked out the window
and obviously was a plane flying over
that and he must have been curious about
it and said oh what's that I want to get
and then they said I like top secret
something and then he probably kept
asking questions saying he wanted to get
involved and then he found out about it
and say oh this is horrific
yeah maybe I mean it kind of it's a
little murky but it's not anything that
makes a story or anything but we get you
you know Moloch again and Rorschach kind
of taking the drugs from him rush I can
you know despite your shabby logical
wait up on the day I'm like what's legal
drug wise and yeah well you obviously
like research and stuff like this and it
probably obsesses over it and reads
legislations every day and so he knows
the ins and outs of what's good and
what's bad but it's actually quite good
to see that he sort of forgives Moloch
for having me
drugs because you've got cancer and and
you know Moloch is a reformed villain
like it is clear that he's not out doing
like villainous acts again and so you
know maybe I mean we do I have said
several times of Moloch's is sorry
washout is very black-and-white but this
kind of you know shows that maybe he
isn't completely because he lets them
off the hook crab nice and apparent
cancer saving drugs and obviously the
cancer ties to the list
he's on with Janey Slater mentioned yet
median so that's kind of just a little
kind of inference there as well and then
we pretty much know going into
Rorschach's journal to end the whole
issue yeah and wash I kind of close that
we have him walking across the sort of
the porno areas that the downtrodden
there's an Oleg a and the little boys is
referenced to the yeah the Hashima bomb
drop which is getting nice as well
I love the whole American love like coke
and green glass bowls and I make any
like you know it's beautiful stuff that
raw egg comes out with always yes it
here and him going back to the funeral
you know back specifically to the grave
plot and you know clearly the whole
story has really stuck with him there's
a certain respect me as for the comedian
that has lending to investigate mhm yeah
and he did he is like very sorrowful he
seems to be the only one who's kind of
mourning on cuz you went back to revisit
his grave and pays respects because yes
you couldn't do it in the day and but
then you get a flashback of all the
horrendous thing yeah the comedians done
and you get there's absolutely brilliant
joke at and the atomic on it's very like
well toll and it's sort of I mean I
don't know if you want to read it I was
quite long but yeah but I mean the whole
I mean the Pagal Ichi is they kind of
like go through the crown or to you I
was doctor I am the clown which is you
know the classic joke but yet so many
doctor says he's depressed them and
basically the doctor says or I know that
the perfect treatment for you to cheer
you up
go see the clown and he says I am the
clown yeah yeah and then as this jokes
being told you see comedian at the end
of Modocs bed with the drink pouring out
it looks very like a confessional yeah
yeah there's the clearly the cross yeah
hanging above his head and it's very
clearly pointing towards religious
aspects of humanity when you know that's
finally confession all of the bad deeds
that they're done seek and righteousness
and forgiveness and the the bottom of
this which is I am plagued lead to him
being thrown out we see the exact same
image at the start pretty much of issue
one definitely what said then is ground
floor coming up and now it's the more
elevated
I am Pagliacci I don't know this image
crops up again very well my they are
thought was Pagliacci paglia gone well
don't a in the commenting on I mean all
our Italian bread did abide using it
when I was telling the joke exactly but
that and I remember it could did a song
on it and it basically the whole song
was about this choke yeah but didn't you
endo mention it as well the battle
rapper yeah yeah yes I think he did me
neither
well saying that he will have read
Watchmen 75 times but innuendo probably
never read anything no no you probably
think it was a gay slur or something
impressed I wash [ __ ] men right like
and then we get you know comedian again
we see we've heard that the forces so
hard they'd send his skull up into his
stomach or some [ __ ] like that so he
drops to the ground the red fades to the
red of you know the Rose and it's a
brilliantly kind of choir ending
Rorschach cutting the roses appellant
walking out this graveyard
yeah make to be honest Rorschach is like
the the most likable character I find
yeah because of these somber moments
like this like he does seem the only
person who still wants to do good in the
world
and I mean he might not go about the
best way but he's got a good heart in
this kind of confirms that
and we end as we always do with the sort
of the full quotes of the song which is
the Elvis Costello song and I'm up all
the dawn is breaking even though my
hiking I should be drinking a toast
absent friend instead of these comedians
so yeah which is perfect quote yes you
you would you would think that Alan Lord
made that up yeah yeah and he might have
just made it up input elvis because
Elvis Costello on the end night you know
we might not have M a big Elvis Costello
fan so don't know but it's the perfect
perfect quote yet of the issue yeah yeah
yeah I don't know I asked my dad why do
you wanna miss Costello guys are sort of
a little bit of this stuff but I could
definitely imagine him singing this and
yeah the final thing as everywhere these
issues is the kind of the back pages the
sort of the written text here we have
under the hood chapter three under the
hood is some of my favorite stuff
actually of these written stuffing
qualities or bug these really
interesting this is more about the sort
of formation of the Minutemen I mean I
get general points we've an interesting
point one of the ones that I liked was
him getting his nickname from like a
police officer as an insult yeah oh yeah
definitely and it's just a great issue
like this I think it's much better than
the first story and this is a lot more
superhero centric and yeah and I just
really enjoyed reading this one and I'm
not a big reader if it's not because if
it doesn't have a little drawing beside
it and so yeah it's just really good to
get into and you know the story of how
he had like you know he regionally drug
through a cave and they went without it
and then yeah how we almost got like
knife through his mask and stuff right
yeah and he got pulled down over his
face and he couldn't see what was going
on exactly and which kind of yeah it
kind of speaks to the impracticality of
having a costume and so like the cape
obviously dollar bill got murdered for
having one and and in the Incredibles
that they clearly say like don't ever
have a cape yeah yeah I don't know if
that kind of was taken from Watchmen but
em yeah don't have a cake and this the
one of the only surviving members didn't
advocate and that's probably why I
literally yeah yeah
and yet the story of dollar bill who you
know gets caught in this the door
doesn't he is caping it shot basically
yes which is which is kind of a love
that story of dollar bill is what
interesting and I love the picture as
well of the x-men of the ex the x-men
the the need to watch for an x-men
crossover but of the the Minutemen
Christmas party so many things to like
in the creature I mean first of all
being it says being captain metropolis
in the mirror you can sort of see Liam
holding a glass obviously him you can
see the camera being hold but the night
that is molix weapon that they're using
like as a backdrop yeah and then you've
got the comedian they're kind of being a
bit forward to the whole of justice
looking on crying with you find out that
how did Justice dated and Silk Spectre
in this yeah yeah it's like the reason
you slip none angrily at the comedian
you've got Mothman with these masks off
looking quite she pursed yeah yeah it's
just a dollar bill a nightgown looking
quite superhero occasionally yeah yeah
we're here all's well it said of the way
everyone else looks kinda out a place of
it and there's tons of great stuff here
like they mentioned captain metropolis
being a Nazi and that kind of ties into
the black unrest stuff and very dark but
Sally Jupiter's agent pressured her it's
not pressing charges against comedian
the publicity would be sobered yeah and
it's just it's interesting actually got
into this to be a model and it kinds of
it's a bit like Instagram to to me but
like she's found this caused to attach
yourself onto you know when you see like
Facebook models with their profile
picture and they do it like with it
filter on to either say that the support
gay pride or right branch when those the
terrorist attacks and they sort of try
and tie in and modeling with like a
cause so the two are aligned and it gets
the more publicity and it's sort of
similar to that in the way that so
expected you know she'd she was looking
at ways to market herself and this was a
good way to do it
yeah yeah you know I might be wrong
no in a maligned way no you're right and
you know it doesn't really one of the
things that doesn't discuss this chapter
I don't think he's really discussing the
book is like the Minutemen like what
that could do as a unit you know what I
mean right right they like if one of the
chapters of him describing like okay
here's the crime we fought and the
people we took down and stuff but
unlikely one I've never actually read
these sections of the book to be honest
there till till it's read through so
it's the one later on or is that just
think Ferg I don't believe what I think
I think there might be another under the
hood chapter but I think in before watch
from they might cover it I don't
actually read that section so yeah I
mean let us know watching the Watchmen
prodigy Montcalm let us know in the
comments we pretty much wrapped up issue
two and it's another incredible issue
death oh yeah hundred percent and just
really good light as when I first
started so are this is going to be a bit
the filler issue but it quickly proves
that it isn't like that my memory of
this a lot of it comes from the film and
so actually we've quite a read dive read
this three or four times that probably
watched the film about to yeah for a
really dirty yet yeah what's your quite
a laugh and it's one of my favorite
comic book films to be honest so
actually reading it again and seeing the
the source material it is a lot better
and it's just nice to revisit these
moments and just see like how stand out
they were like there are quite a lot of
sections and the film that aren't done
perhaps in the best way like one bit
that I read on like is when them the
comedian and night owl attacker citizens
and for some reason I always think all
that's a terrible moment but reading it
in the book it's just really enjoyable
and it is quite a lot going on mm-hmm
yeah ya know entirely obviously we'll
have to get to the movie eventually but
um death this has been great as ever I
guess I'll see you back at issue free
man yeah see you and kids and I want to
say as well subscribe to us on iTunes if
you have yeah you know we're on there
and maybe we'll do some like other comic
book stuff sometime as well I do like
top five favorite you know
non watchmen Starfall yeah whatever I
wouldn't mind turning this into like a
monthly comic book thing and I do it
enough as it is but I want to do more
so yeah I'm up for it all right yeah
well not that it like you've sort of
recorded now so yeah go do it
all right well def as ever man has been
great yeah take it
cheers bye
you